There is an absolutely fascinating and chaotic
war that has developed between Donald Trump
and the Republican Party.
It has the makings of exactly the type of
chaos that could endanger both Donald Trump's
political future and also the viability of
the Republican Party in the 2022 election
cycle.
And not surprisingly, this is all about money.
Back at his CPAC speech a couple of weeks
back, Donald Trump announced that he was not
yet announcing whether he would run in 2024.
He said, we'll see how it goes, but that for
now, donate to him at Donald Trump dotcom.
So that threw his Save America PAC.
He can support the right Republican candidates
in 2022.
And he also went on a very long rant slamming
certain Republicans.
Remember this.
Democrats don't have grandstanders like Mitt
Romney, little Ben Sasse, Richard Burr, Bill
Cassidy, Susan Collins, Lisa Murkowski, Pat
Toomey.
And in the House, Tom Rice, South Carolina,
Adam Kinzinger, Dan Newhouse, Anthony Gonzalez,
that's another beauty.
Fred Upton, Jami Herrera Butler, Peter Meyer,
John Katka, David Valadao and of course, the
war monger, a person that loves seeing our
troops fighting Liz Cheney.
How about that?
So what is this all about?
Quite simply, this is about Trump wanting
to control the Republican Party and to be
kingmaker, Trump doesn't yet know whether
he will run in 2024 because it's not clear
what his position in the Republican Party
is going to be at that time.
That's almost four years away.
For now, most voters in the Republican Party
still support Donald Trump, but many Republican
elected officials don't.
And Trump's best path to 2024 is to be a kingmaker
successfully in twenty twenty two.
In order to do that, he needs to control the
donor money of the Republican Party.
And this has set up a major propaganda and
legal battle between Donald Trump and the
Republican Party, which is just exploding.
The Republican Party says it has the right
period to use Trump's name and likeness for
fundraising purposes.
Donald Trump has sent the Republican Party
a cease and desist letter saying, stop using
my name, stop using my likeness to raise money
for the Republican Party.
Trump wants to raise the money himself for
his PAC and then decide who to support in
2022 and which Republicans to try to primary
and remove in 2022.
And he doesn't want to be competing with his
own name and image used by the Republican
Party to raise money, maybe as he would see
it, to support the wrong Republicans.
He doesn't want his name being used to raise
money by the GOP to then support the reelection
of Liz Cheney, for example, or Mitt Romney,
for example.
So the legal battle is going to continue.
I don't know how that will go.
I mean, it's a does the Republican Party have
a right to monetize a former president's name
and likeness?
I don't know the answer to that.
That's a legal question.
But in the meantime, Donald Trump has released
a wild attack letter, the likes of which we've
never seen ever from a former president against
their own party.
Writing yesterday in a statement by Donald
Trump, No more money for rhinos.
RINO means Republican in name only.
They do nothing but hurt the Republican Party
and our great voting base.
They will never lead us to greatness.
Send your donation to Save America PAC at
Donald Trump Dotcom.
We will bring it all back stronger than ever
before.
A former Republican president is saying Do
not donate to my party to the Republican Party.
Donate to me instead of former president sending
a cease and desist letter to their own party
saying, don't mention me in trying to raise
money.
And so this is unprecedented, of course, but
it's a grift on a few different layers.
First of all, Trump wants to control the money
because that's Trump's whole life, control
the money, not someone else.
That that's been Trump's entire career.
Number two, Republican voters are willing
to donate some amount of money each election
cycle.
Trump wants it to go to him rather than to
someone else so that he can play kingmaker.
Secondly, Trump can't tolerate any dissent.
So he has this list of enemy Republicans,
rhinos, who he might even try to get primary
challengers against for 2022.
And he wants to control that.
That's another reason why he says donate to
him, not to the Republican Party.
And third, he wants to keep his options open
for 2024.
And in order to do that, him controlling the
Republican Party in 2022 is the natural and
most obvious path.
Now, there's maybe a fourth, which is Trump
maybe can use some of this money of either
towards campaign debt or keep it if he does
eventually run in twenty, twenty four instead
of using it in twenty twenty two.
That really depends on the specifics of how
this PAC is set up.
I emailed a couple of lawyers this morning
asking whether this is possibly what Trump
is also doing.
Haven't heard back yet, so we'll look into
that more.
But that's potentially the fourth layer of
the grift.
And that's what Trump did with his fundraising.
I think it was 70 something million after
the November twenty twenty election saying
give me money to try to overturn the election
results and fund recounts in Georgia and all
this stuff.
He kept most of the money for his own campaign
debt.
So that's the latest with Trump Trump in the
Republican Party.
Now they're officially at war.
This is Trump declared war against a certain
slate of Republicans at his CPAC speech two
weeks ago.
And now Donald Trump declaring legal war against
the Republican Party, sending a cease and
desist letter